in the heart of Ukraine a quiet
Revolution
stirs the creation of new tools of
War built by volunteers and students and
technicians tinkerers who are
repurposing their skills to resist
Invasion we partnered with the keev
Independent to get a deeper
understanding of what this actually
looks like this is their
story and the story of how set they are
on keeping their
country not by having bigger
weapons but by having smarter
[Music]
ones
okay can you hear me all right yeah I
can hear you how you doing this is
Francis for
a reporter from Ukraine's largest
English language news Outlet the KE
independent they've been covering this
war in depth and they worked with us to
tell this story how is Kia feeling these
days it's this kind of tense waiting
period cuz everyone's ready for uh
another kind of wave of Russian missile
and D attacks against the Energy System
I want to hear about your time on the
front lines and I want to hear about
drones and just walk me through that
story 11:00 in the morning we met our
contact we jumped in his car and headed
out straight towards the city of buak
mut which is now basically in
[Music]
ruins it was pretty quiet but then we
started to get hit by Russian shelling
by m shelling you can hear the whistle
coming in and the explosion you can feel
it in the ground when it's really
close
and when the time came a Target was was
acquired and it was time to go out and
fly they had the Drone ready with the
munition on it and what did the drone
look like can you describe it so it's an
fpv drone so it's a quadcopter but it's
a very kind of crude uh designs and on
the bottom you have the actual munition
strap it's actually made from a
helicopter rocket they cut the rocket
part off and they just used the
Warhead the pilot put on these crazy
futuristic goggles and had the
controller in his
[Music]
hand but at that point you start to see
this Russian electronic warfare jamming
stuff uh starting to kick in so it
really is like oh the Signal's gone oh
now it's back there's a button somewhere
that's like okay this is where we
release the
bomb so a lot of the drones that they're
using in Ukraine actually look a lot
like the drones I use when I'm I'm out
reporting in the field which I'm going
to get to in a little bit I need to tell
you about something which is Spam spam
spam spam is taken over all of our lives
our phones blow up our email is a mess
spammers will text you it's all gotten
out of control if you've ever wondered
how spammers get your information the
answer is they probably bought it there
is an entire Market out there that none
of us know about where your information
is bought and sold they know your name
your age where you live your phone
number your email address what you buy
online your browsing history all of this
has been collected and sold around on
these massive lists the good news here
is that we have the right to demand that
our name and information be taken off
these lists the bad news is that it's
really hard and cumbersome to do this
and there's like hundreds of lists all
of this brings me to the sponsor of
today's video which is incog a tool that
I am so grateful exists because what
they do is they go out and they take you
off of these lists you don't have to do
anything you sign up for in cogy you
give them permission to act on on your
behalf and then they go out and they
find the lists that you're on and they
start demanding that you be taken off if
any of these data Brokers push back
incog continues to push them until all
of your information is deleted from
these lists I signed up for this a while
back when they came to sponsor a video
and it has changed my world my phone
doesn't blow up anymore my email is way
more under control and the best part is
I get to track the progress I have this
like dashboard where I get to see how
many requests they've sent out how many
have been successful how many they're
still working on and month after month
they continue to guard my privacy I
sleep much better at night knowing that
I'm not on some like people search site
where people can just look up where I
live or that my browser history
information isn't being used to like
raise my insurance premium which is a
thing that happens if you too want to
take back your privacy there's a link in
my description when you click the link
it helps support the channel and it gets
you in on a big discount 60% off the
annual plan of incog I do the annual
plan so that they're constantly
monitoring and taking me off these lists
I am really glad incog exists and I'm
really grateful that they sponsor
sponsored today's video that they
support our journalism so with that
let's dive back into this video about
drones in Ukraine francis's reporting
shows us how this war the war in Ukraine
is becoming more and more a war of
drones that's what this war is all about
really it's this is this mix of very old
school brutal tactics of infantry and
artillery but with this Hightech Edge
some of these drones are military
weapons designed for Warfare but more
and more were seen drones being made in
homes and classroom rooms and DIY
workshops around the country by students
and volunteers overnight drone experts
who bypass the Ukrainian Army and send
their drones directly to soldiers on the
front line This is where War becomes
really almost scary and futuristic to
understand how drones became a
centerpiece of this War and why
engineering students are the ones making
them we have to remember how the war
started Putin has just launched a
fullscale invasion of
Ukraine since the beginning of this
conflict Ukraine's biggest weakness has
been the
sky Russia has a much stronger Air Force
and they quickly developed air
superiority this allowed them to better
gather intelligence support their ground
troops and precisely deploy missiles
this was Russia's huge Advantage Ukraine
needed a way to fight back and so they
started turning to military drones the
bayar the Turkish made weapon Ukrainian
officials are touting as one of the most
effective in their Arsenal that's played
a part in slowing down the Russian
advance but drones like this kind of
resemble traditional airplanes they're
easily spotted and shot down by Russia's
anti-aircraft weapons they needed to
find another way they needed eyes in the
sky that's literally how they they tell
me every time and so very quickly there
was a frenzy to buy DJI civilian drones
you know for hobbyists for for
photographers YouTubers this is actually
the type of drone that I've always used
when I do my field shoots and I got to
say it's a pretty useful tool for the
use case of the Ukrainian Army it's
light it's portable it's cheap and it's
small enough to not be detected by
Russian radar and very quickly they
figured out how to integrate them with
their tactical Maps learned how to
jailbreak the software to get around the
Geo blocking soon you've got Ukrainian
soldiers writing back to their families
asking for supplies and bulletproof vest
and more and more asking for drones
these DJI drones became really useful
for helping UK soldiers have a
reconnaissance View from Above they
could see the lay of the land it also
helped them more accurately pinpoint
their targets these big artillery guns
they were using IM immediately became
the bread and butter for any Ukrainian
unit and then from there The Innovation
just really began to to get
going these DJI drones were useful but
they had limits DJI which is a Chinese
company is not thrilled about their
drones being used in war especially by
the ukrainians so they make big efforts
to block software and Hardware from
getting into the country these drones
are also vulnerable to Russian jamming
basically you can jam the signal and
make these drones basically useless also
you can't really customize a DJI drone
that much Ukrainian soldiers needed to
be able to customize their drones more
and more as the war progressed and that
led to the rise of the fpv
[Music]
Drone these drones are usually used for
like racing or for getting shots like
[Music]
this the strength of the fpv Drone is
that they're easily put together with
cheap parts and they can be highly
customized With a Little Help From a 3D
printer on the battlefield Ukrainian
soldiers started taking these little fpv
drones and strapping explosives to them
carrying it across the front line and
then barreling right into a Russian
Target these cheap drones became the
edge that Ukraine needed to level the
plane Field in in the sky but there was
one major problem they get destroyed
constantly and obviously kamakazi drones
are only meant to be used once they're
also uh kind of expendable material in
the front line soldiers began using a
lot of these things like by one estimate
they're using 10,000 of these drones per
month and if a unit doesn't get the
replaced very very quickly they can be
in big trouble on their little part of
the front line and yet the flow of
drones kept coming thanks in part to a
widespread effort a Grassroots effort
all around the country from resourceful
ukrainians who saw an opportunity to
apply their technical skills to
supporting their
[Music]
country the KF independent helped us
connect with some of these drone makers
they are technicians Engineers some of
them are students a lot of them are
volunteers and they are the ones keeping
these drones flowing to the front
[Music]
lines
this guy Dennis lupenko used the money
and infrastructure from his existing
business but redirected it to making
drones this informal drone economy has
cropped up organically and it's
widespread a lot of people are
participating in it but it's outside of
the authority of the government or the
military it's yet another expression of
how ukrainians are resourcefully
fighting back in light of their country
being invaded by a much stronger power
so you have it Specialists you have
engineers and you basically have this
nation which is is just very experienced
with tinkering and experimenting and
coming up with Solutions on the spot for
really tricky problems that got the
technical background and now there's
motivation
[Music]
very often you see fundraisers just
scrolling through Instagram stories
organized by friends of soldiers who
know that there are people out there on
the front line they need a drone so you
have started to see that the tactics of
drones on the battlefield are evolving
really quickly they're starting to
settle into some main tactics that
drones are now being used for all of the
time a first major one is Recon and
intelligence gathering drones being
undetectable eyes in Sky allow Ukrainian
soldiers to get a lay of the land in a
way that you can't really get any other
way unless you have like a full-blown
Air Force they're able to track and view
their adversary's troop movement and
crucially they're able to investigate
their targets before they try to hit
them when you're shooting these big
artillery guns it's kind of a game of
guess and check you shoot the gun you
hope it hits the target and then if it
doesn't you adjust it and try again when
you have a drone in the air to abs
observe where that shot actually hits
you can more precisely calibrate your
gun so that you're hitting your target
more accurately but with the rise of fpv
drones and all of this customization
you're starting to see drones become
carriers of explosives bigger and bigger
explosives just like what Francis saw a
customized explosive that is attached to
a drone with a greedy printed quick
release that with the Press of a button
can release the explosive on the desired
Target and then of course there's the
kamakazi tactic which is just to strap
an explosive to a drone and run it right
into a Target like a tank this
effectively turns your cheap drone into
a Precision guided missile something
that would cost orders of magnitude more
but as these techniques become more and
more sophisticated so do the
counterattacks Russia counters all of
this not only with drones of their own
they now have fleets of drones that they
are using to attack Ukrainian cities but
also with electronic warfare which
basically means jamming signals this
whole tactic relies on radio signals
that allow a pilot to see where they're
flying and to control the Drone remotely
Russia is getting better and better at
putting out signal Jammers to stop
pilots from seeing and controlling their
drone you can see some of this
interference happening in some of these
drone feeds and when your drone looks
like that and you can't control it it
basically renders it useless so to
counter this Ukrainian soldiers now put
up drones that are specifically meant to
boost their signal to create kind of a
bridge of a radio signal that will
counteract this electronic warfare and
secure a more solid signal between the
pilot and the Drone the cat and mouse
game here is kind of the Wild West for
Warfare and it is pushing drone Warfare
into Uncharted Territory and finally
these drones on the front lines are
being used to capture video which is
then edited together and usually set to
like some hardcore rock music and
published to the internet to boost
morale in this
war morale is a key ingredient to
winning a war and War propaganda is as
old as War itself so when ukrainians see
this footage of a Ukrainian pilot
cleverly taking out a Russian Target it
has a real
effect
yeah the rest of the world is watching
this as it unfolds this is unprecedented
territory strapping explosives to small
consumer drones and using them in a real
world Warfare experience so this is
going to change War forever and in fact
we're already seeing this the Pentagon
recently released this proposal for
small businesses in America to pitch
them on how to build a small explosive
or munition that they can put on a small
drone this is a part of their Innovation
and research effort they say here in
this document that the ability to put
explosives on small drones is vital for
the future of army combat operations and
that their ability to do this would
would Advance the US Army's
modernization priorities they're
basically saying that drones are a big
part of the future of war and they
emphasize that whatever this product is
it needs to be attachable by a soldier
in the field meaning someone's out there
on the front lines and they can take
this explosive they can put it on a
drone and they can send it away exactly
what they're doing in Ukraine the
Pentagon is watching what is happening
and they are responding but for those
caught in the middle of this deadly War
drones are about one thing right now and
that's survival survival of their
country as this conflict grinds on
ukrainians continue to show us just how
serious they are about enduring this
long fight by coming together by
supporting their troops and endlessly
innovating and in the process ensuring
that their country doesn't get swallowed
by their much larger
enemy
[Music]
forign
hey folks thanks for watching I loved
working on this story because I got to
talk to people on the ground I got to
like interface with the experience of
ukrainians and Tinkers and Defenders of
their country I mean it was really
compelling I'm really grateful for all
of those who spoke to us um I want to
tell you about a couple things number
one I don't know if you all know this
but we have a second Channel now it's
called search party it is a geopol
political and Global Sports explainer
channel turns out geopolitics and sports
are becoming more and more intertwined
and um this channel really breaks it
down it is run by my old Vox colleague
Sam Ellis who is the creator of Vox
Atlas and now he runs search party so go
over and subscribe we have a lot of
amazing videos coming out and um you
won't want to miss them if you like this
stuff here you'll like the stuff over
there I want to say thanks to all the
members of The Newsroom which is our
patreon The Newsroom members contribute
to our journalism and return they get a
behind the scenes Vlog every month they
get access to my scripts they get
royalty-free music and they get the warm
fuzzy feeling that they are supporting
our journalism we want to do deeper and
deeper videos over on The Newsroom they
allow us to do that to level up to be
more ambitious other ways to support
include Luts and presets which we use to
color our photos and videos all the
links are in the description as per
usual and um you know the best support
is just just being here watching the
videos commenting sharing whatever I
really love the feedback that I get from
everybody I love the good discussions
and the comments and um I'm just happy
that we can continue to make good stuff
so thanks for being here and I'll see
you in the next
one hey before you go I need to tell you
one last thing which is that we made
probably our last batch of the poster
that I designed last year it's a poster
called all maps are wrong and I'm very
proud of it it shows all the ways that
you can take our Earth and project it
onto a 2d plane which always comes with
some Distortion anyway it's kind of a
nerdy map lover thing and if you're into
that you should go over and check it out
before they're all gone this is probably
going to be our last batch so get them
while they lost and uh the Link's in the
[Music]
description